[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today uh
there's a viral video that I I want to
uh have you guys weigh in on so James uh
set this up for us because we've not
seen it yet so what what's going on yeah
it came up in one of our content
meetings this morning and it seemed like
the perfect thing for you because it
revolves around work okay and it's it's
one of those things where you watch it
once and you have a certain reaction and
then as it sinks in you're kind of like
there's a deeper thing there so I didn't
want to set it up too much more than
that all right let's roll
it work until we have to die just for
the privilege of being alive we have to
work somewhere just to afford a house
that we're never at because we're
working to afford the house is the
meaning of life to work and pay taxes
and then die on top of that we also have
to work to afford our vehicle to get to
work in other places and afford gas just
to get to work and we also have to pay
taxes for our roads to drive on to get
to work and then we have to work for our
children to go to school to learn how to
work so our children know how to work
for their children so that their
children can go to school and go to work
like somebody tell me that this is fair
like is it lazy to just want to enjoy
life like why do why do we have to work
why I'm stressed I just check my student
loans because I need interesting so this
went viral you said yeah okay well okay
couple things John
um I I can see the tendency for some to
just you know lay into this young lady
and the snowf flaker and and and and
these things and I've seen some of these
before and have made those comments but
I I got something a little different
here I don't
see lazy spoiled entitlement although I
could understand if some see that I see
uh a little bit of desperation and I
think I see a whole lot of no
understanding and that's not her fault
here's what I mean by that I don't think
the adults in her life and I'm not just
laying out the parents here but we
adults in her life whoever we is we've
not done a good job of explaining that
there is
contribution that is involved with work
yes we've got to work for provision does
that
suck sort of kind of if that's the way
you look at it right but I didn't see I
saw sadness I saw a lack of what is the
whole point of all this I want to enjoy
she should we enjoy life I think the
answer is emphatically yes but I think
when we see work as just this thing to
get a
paycheck and it's gonna
suck uh and I got to just muddle through
it and the way she laid it out I do
think that's the way a lot of people
look at work I mean I we did a
curriculum at Ramy Solutions uh that
that that we talked about this with high
school students and I asked about the
dream job and I said what does that mean
to you and to a kid they said
it's this idea of this thing I'd like to
do but I have no chance of doing it so
if you look at that then the idea of
enjoying work and showing up and doing
something that is Meaningful when you do
your show and you meet people in a place
of pain and you step in with them and
you give them hope I mean that's
rewarding and I just don't think she's
been taught that there is a reward to
work Beyond a dollar and I think we
failed in that regard I'm gonna say that
yeah and I think I think if the only
places you work are
soulless giant corporations that you
know the only thing you're contributing
to is a few people at the top getting
rich you're not you haven't connected
what you do to you're not solving a
problem for somebody y um you are a cog
in a machine you're a car in a traffic
jam then that sort of desperation Rings
true and I get that yep um I've had to
explain to people who aren't in our
ecosystem like I've had to go develop
Hobbies cuz I like work because I've
always tried to be about solving a
problem for somebody right and I like
doing that and so it it here here's when
I get Crossways and when I just sitting
with people who struggle with mental
health
challenges when I have a day off and I
plan quote unquote I'm gonna do nothing
I'm just GNA do nothing tomorrow
inevitably about 11:00 I am about a
th000 calories more in than I normally
am I feel miserable my neck hurts cuz
I've been laying cocki watching some
stupid show that like we were not made
to do nothing you say this better than
anybody we're made to contribute to
something bigger than we are and this is
a voice I think generationally that I
wish politicians would listen to that's
right we don't have a Lost Generation of
quote unquote snowflakes we don't have a
because if you if you work with these
they work hard and they weirdly care
deeply they just have come to understand
oh we are playing somebody else's game
we're contributing to nothing other than
getting our boss another retirement home
and I'm out I'm out they've done the
math John they have they realize that
the average American they don't walk
around saying this but they've watched
their parents and grandparents work what
amounts to about 90,000 hours in their
lifetime and they get laid off and
they're going they get dropped they get
they get cancer and they're like oh
that's it that's this is it this is what
we I think this group has a chance to
transform workers we know it absolutely
but uh as I've said a million times if
you spend the majority of your day using
what you do best these are things you're
good at yeah to do work you enjoy to
produce a result that you care about
right that's really rewarding and you
can't wait to get up and go do it again
you can't um you and I both we share
this I mean you stick us on a stage
where we're answering questions with
real people we'll stand up there for
hours well you and I fly across the
country and leave our families that's
how much we
love and so what is that so that's for
for us that's helping people with that
but for other people it's welding right
for other people it's teaching for other
people it's being in a hospital and
being bone tired and taking one more
surgery because you know that you can
help and you love it I sat with some
guys from Hiller electric I don't mind
call them out they came to my house when
our power went out and my power is
connected to our well so we had no water
we had no power and those
guys wake up every day and say we can
help a family have a better day today
and they just keeps going and going they
have purpose behind the is is it hot yes
is it exhausting yes is it the worst yes
and there's a purpose tied to it that's
right and so I think here's my dream I
wish every leader whether you have five
people working for you or you're run a
huge restaurant chain and you have
50,000 you're not just making Burgers
you're helping this person find a little
bit of margin in time and eat so that
they can be with their kids or they if
you connect your even your front level
employees to how we're helping somebody
today yes people get they you just
become a part of it here's what I wish I
could do I wish I could hop in the car
with her and go hey tell me what you're
really good at doing and we'd hear and
we'd hear some awesome things and we'd
say who are the people you really want
to help or what are some of the problems
in the world that make you upset and and
you would be rewarded if you solved
those problems and you begin to paint a
picture that she has a unique design
plus a unique story that tied together
she's got something where she goes I
would actually be really rewarded and
fired up to go do that oh and by the way
make some money have some life balance
leave work at work yes go home love with
my friends travel the world yes do some
cool things give some of that money to
somebody or like Tara the person who
takes care of our calendar if you ask
her what do you put on Earth to do to be
the best executive assistant who ever
lived yeah those kind of things make me
want to pull my fingernails out I get it
and every day she wakes up and she's
like I'm going to go make
I'm going to do the best job I can and
then these guys are going to get where
they need to go and they're going to to
be with their families and like it
doesn't matter what you're what what
what jazzes you up doesn't have to be an
Instagram reel so but go find that thing
culture what we've done here and adults
what we've done here is we've given
these kids the wrong picture of life
it's not work 990,000 hours hope to have
enough left over in your 401k that
that's when I get to enjoy life we
painting an incomplete picture to buy
the fanciest car to get you to the job
work for contribution and adjust your
lifestyle of that I keep coming back to
every time we have these discussions to
the largest millionaire study ever done
by Ramsey Solutions and teachers a
median salary in the United States right
now of 61,000 and arguably one of the
worst workplaces in America right now
they're they're leaving in droves but
they're everyday millionaires why they
make peace with the Corolla that's it
you nailed it they make peace with a
Corolla it's a great car get me to and
from I'm going to go help kids and
they're fine with it because they know
they're turning on light bulb every day
and kids that they're teaching are
changing the world appreciate the video
James that really is a big Grand disc
try to track her down on Instagram let's
have her on the show wouldn't that be
great to actually have her on that's a
brilliant idea this is the ramsy show
create your free every dooll budget
today the simplest way to budget for
your life